how are you how's the baby it's been
really hard for me
um anxiety well I cried non-stop all day
for the first three weeks emotional
roller coaster it's just the baby blues
and then it kind of goes away had it
with stormy too like fried for like
three weeks I believe you like every day
to the point where I'd be laying in bed
in my head which is hurt so bad Kylie
Jenner opens up about postpartum baby
blues deep down like I would love my
true fans to know like all my personal
stuff the beauty Mogul makes the
confession on the latest episode of who
loss the Kardashians during a chat with
her sister Kendall I'm not a doctor but
I read on Google they call it baby blues
when it doesn't last past
six weeks and after about six weeks I
started to feel better but I definitely
had
the case of the Blues but I feel better
mentally I'm not crying every day so
that's great I get what you're saying
like I don't have bad days with my body
I have bad days like mentally Kylie and
Travis Scott welcome to their second
child together a son whose name they
have yet to reveal back in February baby
number two congratulations thank you the
two also share a four-year-old daughter
stormy
[Music]
and while Kylie says things have been
tough mentally and physically she's
fully embracing her body after baby I
feel really like good about my body like
I see my body and I'm like I love my
body as you should my saggy person
I'm embracing my PP body postpartum oh
but this isn't the first time she's
gotten candid about her postpartum
struggles I just want to say to my
postpartum moms that postpartum has not
been easy
it's not been easy it's very hard
it's this experience for me personally
has been a little harder than with my
daughter
it's not easy mentally
physically spiritually Kylie kept it
real with her fans on Instagram back in
March hoping to encourage other moms who
might be dealing with the same issues
it's okay not to be okay once I
realized that I was putting some
pressure on myself and I just keep
reminding myself I made a whole human
beautiful healthy boy and we have to
stop putting pressure on ourselves to
be back not even physically just
mentally
um after after birth so yeah just
sending some love
[Music]